So the answer is, at this point, x references the object 3 which is an integer.
So it has type int. After the next assignment, now x references the string,
hello udacious one, which has type str. At this point, while we're inside the
definition of the function double, double takes a parameter named x. Note that
this is a different x from that x. This x is defined inside the body of the
double procedure. This one is visible outside it. We don't actually know what
object this x references yet. It doesn't reference as an object until we call
double and pass in a value. So its value is actually unknown. So at this point,
the object x with references unknown and the type of x is also unknown, but
importantly, this is a different x from that one. The type of that x is still
type str. After the last assignment and I didn't make this part of the quiz, the
type of x is now type function. And the point of this quiz is to illustrate that
Pythons types are dynamic. And the real emphasis of that is the fact that the
type of x at this point could be unknown. We can define a function, have a
variable named x. It doesn't have a type until it's associated with an object.